at what point do you
realize must have been early but music
cuz music is you know it's so
interesting if I'm talking if anyone's
listening to this interview and they're
thinking I've heard of Reggie Watts but
I don't know his his whole thing of
course and you're well known as band
leader for Cordon for all those years
and Comedy Bang Bang but but it's my
highest compliment I can pay to you is
that you are impossible to categorize
because you're he's like he's a musician
yeah he's a band leader well but he's
also he's a comedian yeah but he's also
an artist but he's also a perform but
he's also a prankster it's like which I
think is is great you're it's like you
you refuse to be categorized but music
must have come to you very early I would
think music I think music is the secret
weapon I think I think for me growing up
I I loved music my parents loved music
they listened to it my dad was a huge
Jazz head um and my mom and he like
shared their love of jazz but also
specifically like U more funk like like
James Brown and things things of that
nature and my mom loved folk music like
you know Nana musuri and those those
types of Eddie PF and those types of
singers um Julio glacius and so I was
around so much music Ray Charles was
someone I gravitated to as a kid I love
watching the way that he moved when he
played piano and then um and weird for
some weird reason Elvis Presley it was
like a huge my first record was an Elvis
Presley record I I just I was impressed
with the Press but um he was uh you can
that's that's
trademarked you will have to Meep that
no one's ever said that about Elvis
Presley no one's ever and everything's
been said about him and no one's ever
said I'm impressed with the
Press I feel fondly for the lee lee
press Lee what Lee for the Lee F Lee for
the Lee what the I told you
what did
you um no I mean but discovering music
like my parents saw me like on my I
would I would be like bedside pretending
to be Ray Charles I was a mimic as far
back as I can remember and they saw me
doing that and they got me this toy
piano and I was playing on the toy piano
a lot and then as soon as we moved to
Montana I think at age like five and a
half or something like that I went into
um uh classical piano training and took
to it pretty well and I loved but I
social so for me it was like oh I get to
be with all these kids and like I'll
learn music but what about all these
kids you know the music was fascinating
but um really I think that's what
creates that adaptability because for me
the one thing I always tell all my
artist friends where they're like you
know I'm doing this one thing but I'm
not sure I thinking about maybe doing
painting I'm like those are just
extensions of yourself it's like if you
imagine yourself as like a person
sitting on a on a floor and you're
surrounded by all these different medium
tools you can rotate to any position and
pick one it's like this the core is
always the same you're the Creator pick
different tools but you've got the most
important part which is like I have an
idea of something I want to do and so
for me I think music enabled that
because I would be on the playground it
would save me if you know people would
be like I be hostile towards me and I
would start singing like Olivia Newton
John or something Let's get physical and
they'd be like oh I tried that and I was
again savagely be were you the right
song Let's get physical
physical I know I know how to stop these
Hooligans sure thing O'Brien how about
this for physical yeah hey O'Brian we're
going to beat the out of you no I
don't think so sir for I'm about to sing
a classic tune by Olivia Newton John
what the oh you'll see Let's get
physical
physical no my god when I awoke in the
ICU God there's not one Unbroken bone in
his
body true though true that bully was
Olivia Newton
John I'm just imagining she doing at the
playground just imagining the bullies
going like is that all of them it's like
I don't know actually no I think this
for this pinky it's like okay one done
get out of here Masterpiece
yeah these are bullies that really took
their job seriously and if they found
out later on there there was an unbroken
pinky they were like you know you got to
respect your crap it's a warranty
did the teachers just watch this happen
too are they joining in oh they would
sell seats oh my God yeah obrien left
uppercut obrien watch out there's
another beating of O'Brien everyone to
the north side of the parking
lot R you that we're suspending all
lessons for the
day the SAT has been cancelled the PSAT
has been
cancelled no one's going to
college Good year blimp passes it's
already got like messaging about me the
Conan
beating you know what else can take a
beating a goodye tire
totally